whenever i want to have
a salute come up with a solution to a
problem and i don't have it
my immediate like reaction is to go
outside and go on a walk um i love
walking in all kinds of weather i it's
kind of um it's
just i feel like with the peace and calm
like getting a weight moving away from
the problem and stepping away from it
sometimes i get way better ideas and it
inspires me but i also think there's
something to be said about
not being inspired like not always it's
amazing i feel like sometimes
i get
struck with inspiration for how i want
to explain a khan academy video or how i
want to approach a piece of art or how i
want to um approach a math problem but
sometimes it doesn't come and so i feel
like what the best solution is when you
are trying to get into that creative
zone and you can't it's just do it and
try to do something anyway like
write something or write your equations
try to figure it out and if you make
mistakes that's okay and because it's
something to jump off of and maybe
sometimes seeing what you already know
down on paper can help you come up with
better ideas um and can help you be more
creative forcing yourself to just
conjure a solution simply does not work
instead take a break from the task pick
something else up like physical sport or
even video games and then come back to
the original problem that can do wonders